i think there's got to be a tax
for talented people that don't use their
talents for me it's the other way around
i'm being dead serious with you
if you're talented and you are not using
your talent and you're sitting around i
think we need to tax you the highest
wow not the other way around because if
a person is busting their butt
going out there creating jobs using
their talents to create an economy for
other people
that person needs to pay less taxes if
the person that's not using their
talents that person needs to be taxed
more i mean isn't there a story about it
with the guy
and you know with five talents three
talents
one talent all this other stuff you got
to put your talents to use i think too
many times we
you know we we like to demonize these
guys that are going out and creating
economy and jobs
and and not the other way around the
people that don't want to use their
talents i know
how many people you know adam how many
people you know
that are more talented than you that are
broke oh there's a lot
why a lot of people why aren't they
broke and they're so talented i don't
know what so they're just
they can't get it together i'll give you
my favorite quote literally of all time
let's hear it so have you ever seen the
movie the bronx tale
of course okay chasm mickey mary yes
yeah mickey man robert de niro yes okay
mickey mantle uh
robert de niro is a bunch when's the
last time mickey mouse paid your bills
exactly yeah the my favorite quote
literally of all time
um he says the saddest thing in life
is wasted talent i remember i wrote that
quote down because there was a time in
my life
where i remember saying i'm so talented
i can do whatever i want to do
i can literally become who i want to
become but i'm wasting my time just
doing nonsense partying in south beach
and i said the saddest thing in life
is wasted talent i heard that i wrote
that down yeah i wrote that down
and i read that every it's i still have
a plaque yeah in my room with that
saying so i
i agree you know what i would do if i
was a governor or a small state yeah
just to do a project eight years if i'm
a governor a small state i'd flip taxes
i'd flip it i'd make it progressive but
the other way around
the less you make the more you get the
less you make the more you pay
mind blown the less you make the more
taxes you pay the more you make the less
taxes wow that's going to get people
that's capitalism people are going to be
hustling
guess what that does guess what that
does you know what it does it's going to
motivate people
the people on the bottom are going to
say screw this guy i don't like this guy
no problem go to la think it's just
going to move garcetti would love you
but the other people are getting like
shoot let me just step my game
come to your state you come to my state
you the more
the more jobs you create the less tax
listen
compensation structures are tax
companies
if you think about our tax plan is a
comp plan that's all it is at a sales
company
their comp plan is a tax plan and i
don't know a single company
that grows in sales where they charge
the people that make more money
and they pay them less commission let me
get this straight so if i come to a
company and i'm doing sales
and the more value and revenues i bring
to the money don't i make more
commission
instead of less commission what sales
organization that grows says
the more money you make we pay you less
commission have you ever heard of an
organization
but taxes do and all of these americans
have bought into this progressive tax
system for what
wow who said this because somebody said
the more money you make the more money
you should pay no it should be the other
way around
i say if you are able to create 50 jobs
if i'm running a city and i tell you
you create 50 jobs an average salary of
50
000 of your income okay does that help
my city out
yeah of course does it help your city
out yeah you create how hard is it to
create 50
jobs for city not wait a minute not easy
if it's easy
not easy not easy it's very hard yes i
don't want you to pay taxes
you'll have the lowest level of taxes
you pay you create 50 jobs in my city
are you kidding me you're a hero no it's
the other way around
you created 50 jobs and you're making
money off of these people
and you made 2.2 million dollars last
year shame on you you rich man
what do you mean shame on you it's the
other way around you
you are you have this degree you are so
smart
you are so well read you know about
philosophy you've read all the books in
the world
and you are unemployed for nine straight
months
and you're blaming society for it no
you're gonna be taxed at the highest
level
wow you don't like the city go to a
different city taxing wasted talent i've
never heard that in my life let me put
some intense stuff
let me put it to you this way you know
what are the chance of somebody getting
elected on that campaign
no zero
you